welcome back to CBS s morning you are
looking right now at New York City's
Empire State Building where visitors
will soon be able to go to the newly
renovated one hundred and second floor
observatory now this opens to the public
tomorrow only on CBS this morning tonita
copal has a look at the spectacular
renovation Tony good morning hey good
morning well the view is quite
spectacular from up here I am 1,250 feet
above Manhattan to be exact and starting
tomorrow as you mentioned you can see
this amazing sight for yourself
take a look there's the Brooklyn Bridge
there's the World Trade Center the
Statue of Liberty you can see all the
way up the Hudson River I feel like I
can see my house hi honey good luck with
the paper this morning I'll be home soon
it's called the mast of the Empire State
Building it is the tippy-top many people
think that this was built as a docking
space for blimps and airships in the
1930s it's a lovely idea but
unfortunately historians say that's not
the case but here's what is true until
1930 the Chrysler Building just a few
blocks from here it reigned as the
tallest building in the world it was
about a thousand feet well the team here
at the Empire State Building said that
cannot stand we want that record and
they came up with a plan but it would
have only topped the Chrysler by a few
feet and they were worried so they went
back to the drawing board and added this
200 foot mast that I'm on today just to
be safe and that gave the Empire State
Building its title as the tallest
building in the world when it opened in
1931 and it provided the building with
the iconic design that has graced New
York and the skyline ever since coming
up guys we're going to take a look at
the building's place in popular culture
and also remember some of its biggest
roles on the big screen that is before
this one which should go down in history
of course but for now I will send it
back to you guys ground-level slumming
it in studio 57 pony it's so good you
look so good you don't look like
somebody that just took a red-eye from
California landed and rushed right there
really nicely nicely done let's see in a
little bit yeah thousand feet in the air
is better than espresso I'll take it any
day